Lightsabers in "Star Wars" are a dime
a dozen – but these particular laser
swords tucked into the background of
Ahsoka's ship may have caught your eye.
While watching Episode 3 of "Ahsoka," a
few eagle-eyed "Star Wars" fans may have
spotted a lightsaber collection that
would put General Grievous to shame.
"They are quite elegant, with
several classic design motifs."
The episode opens in the training room
on Ahsoka Tano's starship,
where she and Padawan Sabine Wren
enjoy a brief sparring match.
In the background is an armory packed with a
wide assortment of lightsabers, though oddly,
neither Ahsoka nor Sabine ever mentions this
collection. Plenty of fans online are no doubt
wondering who these weapons belonged to before
they wound up on Ahsoka's ship. Presumably,
a few of them, or possibly all of them,
were constructed by Huyang, since the
ancient droid aided several generations
of Padawans in lightsaber construction.
We know the lightsabers at the top of
the collection are Huyang's work since
he carries four identical sabers during
his training session with Sabine — each
sporting a distinctive circle crossguard
and emitting an abnormally thick blade
for practice. While these lightsabers are
clearly for training only, it's worth noting
they all bear a striking resemblance to the
lightsaber of "Star Wars Rebels" staple Kanan
Jarrus. which also featured a unique circle
crossguard but emitted a blue beam instead.
Far more interesting than the practice
sabers are the more distinctive blades
adorning the training facility's back
wall. Each has an extremely unique design,
which implies that they belonged to other
Jedi before they wound up in Ahsoka's armory.
While none of these lightsabers immediately
jump out as belonging to any known Jedi,
there are a few familiar characteristics
among them. The top right saber and the
leftmost saber on the second row sport a sleeve
of black rings, which is an iconic design on
Obi-Wan Kenobi's and Qui-Gon Jinn's weapons in
"The Phantom Menace." The middle right saber
bears a sleeve with black, blocky protrusions
like the lightsabers of Yoda and Mace Windu,
while the bottom right saber draws
comparisons to blades of Saesee Tiin
and Darth Vader — both of which have
large, protruding activation switches.
The most unique of all these sabers
are the two on the top row. The top
left lightsaber sports a thick black
sleeve not unlike Vader's, though oddly,
it opens up halfway up the hilt — like a mouth
from which the rest of the blade emerges. The
top right weapon is also strange, with
an enormous emitter that juts out above
the blade and seemingly has a chunk cut out.
The overall effect is a group of lightsabers
that look slightly familiar but have not been
connected to any known Jedi, at least not yet.
Unless Ahsoka or Huyang go out of their way to
identify who originally owned these lightsabers,
viewers can only speculate on who they might
have belonged to before the show's events.
If Huyang did not create these lightsabers,
the most likely option is that they belonged
to Jedi that escaped the massacre of Order 66.
Ahsoka could have encountered these survivors
at any point after the Clone Wars, though if
this is the case, it begs the question of why
she took their lightsabers for her own. More
probable is that they were in the possession
of non-Jedi who either stole them or found
them after a fallen Jedi cast them aside.
"Next time, try not to lose it."
"Yes, master."
"This weapon is your life."
In the event that Huyang did construct all these
lightsabers, they were probably made in case
Ahsoka took on another Padawan. If Ahsoka ever
planned to teach other Force wielders the ways of
the Jedi, something she almost agreed to do for
Grogu in "The Mandalorian," it stands to reason
those new Jedi would need lightsabers. If this is
the case, it's somewhat unfortunate that Ahsoka
brought on Sabine Wren as an apprentice, as she
already has a lightsaber courtesy of Ezra Bridger.
Regardless, Ahsoka and company clearly have a
huge number of lightsabers at their disposal,
and one has to wonder if these extra blades will
come in handy as the "Ahsoka" story moves forward.